CALL TO ORDER.
THE UTILITIES AND COMMITTEE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE --
WE ARE SHORT OF A QUORUM BUT I
RECOGNIZE THE PRESENCE OF ONE OF
OUR AUTHORS AND SIR DODD WOULD
LIKE -- TO IF YOU DON'T MIND
OPERATE AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
THEN WE WILL.
TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY [inaudible]
AND WE WELCOME YOU TODAY YOU'RE
HERE TO PRESENT ON SENATE BILL.
TWO FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT ON PAGE SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS.
AS WE ALL KNOW EXTREME WEATHER
IS INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
LENGTH OF THE WILDFIRE SEASON.
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE TWELVE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES IN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WERE CAUSED BY ELECTRIC POWER IN
DISTRIBUTION LIGHTS.
CONDUCTORS AND POWER POLES CAL
FIRE CITED TREES ARE PARTS OF
TREES FALLING ON THE POWER LINES
AS THE SPECIFIC CAUSE FOR THOSE
FIRES.
ADEQUATE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCING.
THE RISK OF TREES AND BRUSH
CONTACTING ELECTRICAL LINES AND
EQUIPMENT.
PART OF CALPERS MISSION IS TO
PREVENT FOREST FIRES FIRES.
I CAL FIRES.
IN A FIRE PREVENTION PROGRAM
INCLUDES WILDFIRE PRE FIRE
ENGINEERING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT FIRE PLANNING
EDUCATION AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN ANY RESTRUCTURING OF THE C..
AS A PERTAINS TO SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT AS SUGGESTED BY THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME LAST WEEK.
CALPERS UNIQUELY SITUATED TO
DETERMINE WHAT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS NECESSARY TO
REDUCE THE CHANCE OF A WILDFIRE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES MUST PROVIDE THE CBC
WITH VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PLAN
AS PART OF THE I. O. U. WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
FURTHER UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
CBC MUST CONSULT WITH CAL FIRE
WHEN REVIEWING AND APPROVING
EACH WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
CAL FIRE TO AUDIT EACH
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK TO
ENSURE THAT THE UTILITIES
SATISFACTORILY CARRIED.
OUT THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WORK SET FORTH IN ITS WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
FINALLY BECAUSE VEGETATION
MANAGE WORK IS VERY DANGEROUS SB
TWO FORTY SEVEN ALSO REQUIRES
THAT THE VEGETATION MAYES WORK
BE PERFORMED.
BY QUALIFIED LYING CLEARANCE
TREE TRIMMERS ARE QUALIFIED
WHITE CLARENCE TREE TRIMMER
TRAINEES.
RECENTLY JUDGE ALSO OVERSEE P.
GENIES PROBATION IN THE SAID
BRITTLE CASE SAID P. JEANNIE
HASN'T CUT THE RIGHT TREES AND
MANAGING VEGETATION.
IN IN NEAR ITS POWER LIGHTS.
IN RESPONSE.
P. JEANNIE SAID AND I QUOTE
THERE'S A LOT OF TREES OUT THERE
AND WE DON'T HAVE ALL HIGHS ON
ALL OF THEM.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I IT'S A BIT
LET'S GET THE ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES THE EYES THE NEED --
TO ADEQUATELY MANAGE EDUCATION
AND CUT THE RIGHT TREES I
BELIEVE WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKE
IT IN THE SENATE.
ALL OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOAT.
WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
I THINK IS THE CHAIR MARK JOSEPH
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA TILL THE EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE CHANCE
OF A FUTURE FIRE BECAUSE UTILITY
FAILED TO TRIM A TREE.
RIGHT NOW THE UTILITY DECIDES
WHAT TREES NEED TO BE TRIMMED.
IT PERFORMS A WORK AND THEN IT
OUGHT ITS ITS OWN WORK.
IT'S MOSTLY DONE WITH
CONTRACTORS.
AFTER A FIRE.
CAL FIRE INVESTIGATES DECIDES
WHAT CAUSED THE FIRE AND
SOMETIMES THEY FIND THAT THE
FAILURE TO TRIM A TREE THAT
SHOULD'VE BEEN TRIMMED WAS THE
CAUSE OF THE FIRE.
NO IT'S REALLY NICE TO KNOW
AFTER THE FACT BUT TO BE MUCH
BETTER IF WE KNEW IT BEFORE THE
FIRE OCCURRED.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE CAL FIRE
AUDIT THE UTILITIES WORK RIGHT
AWAY BEFORE THE FIRE.
AND TELL THE UTILITY IF IT'S
MISS SOMETHING.
THEN THE AGILITY HAS A CHANCE TO
FIX THE MISTAKE RIGHT AWAY.
THEN CAL FIRE REPORTS THE
RESULTS OF ITS AUDIT TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THIS WILL CREATE A VERY POWERFUL
INCENTIVE FOR THE UTILITY TO FIX.
EVERY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROBLEM THAT CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFIES BECAUSE IF IT DOESN'T
AND THAT CAUSES A FIRE.
THERE WILL BE A PAPER TRAIL
SHOWING THE AGILITY WAS WARNED
AND FAILED TO ACT.
WE DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WE EXPECT THE UTILITY TO
JUMP ON EVERY PROBLEM THE
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFIES.
CALIFORNIA AUDITING UTILITY WORK
IS A MUCH BETTER SYSTEM THAN
SELF AUDITING.
THE BILL DOES NOT INCREASE ANY
EXPENSE FOR CALIFORNIA --
BECAUSE CAL FIRE WOULD BE
REIMBURSED BY THE UTILITY FOR
ITS AUDITING WORK.
THE BILL WOULD GREATLY IMPROVE
THE VEGETATION MATTER FOR
PROCESS AND RESULT IN FEWER
FIRES CAUSED BY MISTAKES AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT FOR YOU.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO IF WE CAN
PROSPER MOMENT WILL TAKE A TAKE
THE ROLE.
HOLDEN HERE HOLDING HERE
PATTERSON.
IN HERE BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO HERE CHEN
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
MAYES.
WE'RE SEARCHING.
SHE HERE QUIRK.
WORK HERE REYES.
HERE'S HERE'S SANTIAGO TEAM
THEIR TEAM HERE PHARMACIST
DEVILISH.
MOVE THE BELL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHAT
SHOULD BE AT THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS JUST VERY QUICKLY THE
SECOND PORTION OF THE BILL HAS
TO DO WITH TRYING TO INSURE
BETTER TRAINING.
AND ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE
WORK FORCE THAT GOES OUT AND
DOES THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE VAST AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS DUE TO THE
WILDFIRE THREAT AT ALL THREE OF
THE I. O. U.'S.
WE HAVE A NEW PHENOMENON WHERE
YOU HAVE SEVERAL TIERS OF
SUBCONTRACTORS -- THE TYPICAL
TRIP.
EVEN VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
CONTRACTORS THE UTILITIES USE
HAVE NOW HAVE SECOND AND THIRD
AND FOURTH AND FIFTH TIER
SUBCONTRACTORS IN ORDER TO GET
THE VOLUME OF THE WORK DONE.
THE PROBLEM IS THE TRAINING HAS
A FOLLOW TO THOSE OTHER TWO
YEARS OF OF CONTRACTORS SO THE
NUMBER OF SERIOUS INJURIES AND
DEATHS HAVE -- ESCALATED AT AN
ALARMING RATE SO THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE -- THAT THE I. O. U.'S
INSURER THAT THE WORK FORCE THIS
PERFORMING THAT -- QUALIFIED THE
CLICK THE TREE.
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
THAT THOSE WORKERS ALL BE
QUALIFIED FOR LYING CLEARANCE
TREE TRIMMERS OR TRAINEES AND
THAT WAY WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING PROGRAMS
ARE IN PLACE.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON WE'D
ORIGIN I'VE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
I WE'RE PREPARED TO HE WHO IS IN
FAVOR.
WELL I JUST WELL NOW LET'S GET
THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD -- UNDER STERN I WOULD HAVE
A TWELVE FORTY FIVE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- WITHIN
MOMENTS THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEE NOW I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES -- THIS.
RACE.
JUST A THOUGHT AND I DIDN'T --
SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR BEFORE BUT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PLAN.
HE HAS THIS CONCEPT OF WILLFUL
MISCONDUCT.
A PERHAPS SOMETHING LIKE THIS
COULD BE A PRIME APHASIA CASE OF
WILLFUL MISCONDUCT.
IF -- CAL FIRE WERE TO SAY THAT --
SOMETHING NEEDED TO BE FIXED AND
IT WASN'T FIXED AND THEN WE HAVE
A FIRE CAUSED BY IT JUST A
THOUGHT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
[inaudible]
CRESCENTA.
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU. SEVEN DOT
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL I WILL
BE.
INCLUDES YES STICK WITH
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I REMEMBER
WE STARTED THIS YEAR WITH THE
HEARING WITH THE THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE THE PC AND GUIDE AND
FOLLOWED A FRONT PAGE LA TIMES
ARTICLE -- THAT WAS VERY
CRITICAL OF THE NPCS.
THE HISTORICAL LACK OF OVERSIGHT
IN TERMS OF THESE WILDFIRE AND
MITIGATION EFFORTS -- AND SO --
I I I I LIKE YOUR IDEA ABOUT HOW.
YOU'RE NOT RELYING ON THE PCB
GOING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION TO
CONDUCT THESE AUDITS -- MIGHT MY
QUESTION IS -- IN.
I I KNOW THE REPRESENTATION IS
MADE THAT -- THE EXPECTATION
WOULD BE THAT THE PC WOULD BE
WOULD TAKE ANY NOTIFICATION
SERIOUSLY -- BUT YOU KNOW IS IS
THERE ANY CONCERN THAT.
THAT PERHAPS WE SHOULD GO
FURTHER LIKE LIKE A MAKING SURE
THAT THESE NOT FORGET
NOTIFICATIONS ARE ALSO FILED
WITH.
WHAT WITH WITH THE -- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE -- ADD PERHAPS AN
ANNUAL REPORT OR THE DID YOU
FEEL THAT THAT DE REPORTED THE
PC BE SUFFICIENT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT PUBLIC OVERSIGHT.
OVER THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COMPARED TO WHAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW I THINK THIS
GOES A LONG WAY.
BUT THAT'S AN IDEA THAT -- IT'S
TIME MAY COME.
YEAH DEPENDING UPON THE
TRANSPARENCY OF THE CITY OF THIS
THE CPC ON YEAH AND AND HOW HOW
THAT ENDS UP WORKING.
BUT FOR NOW I DO BELIEVE THIS IS --
YOUR GREAT STEP -- IN.
IN JUST MAKING SURE THAT -- YEAH
WE'RE NOT ALLOWING THE UTILITIES
TO SELF CERTIFY.
THAT THEY'VE DONE THE WORK THAT
HAS NOT WORKED WELL FOR US.
I THANK YOU [inaudible]
DR.
I THINK YOU THINK YOU CENTER FOR
BRING THIS FOR TODAY YEAH I
THINK.
THE IN THE GOAL WAS IN A
STRUGGLE WITH WE'RE LIVING IN
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WERE THE
LANDSCAPE IS CONSTANTLY SHIFTING.
AND THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE OUR OUR FINGERS ON
THAT SO WE CAN SHIP ALONG WITH
IT AND I THINK THE OLD MODELS OF
THE UTILITIES KIND OF MONITORING
THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE CERTAINLY COME TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE DON'T WORK ANYMORE THEY MAY
WORK AT ONE TIME BUT THEY
CERTAINLY DON'T WORK ANYMORE AND
GOING FORWARD I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE.
AS MANY EYES AS WE CAN --
ANYTHING DEPARTMENT FORCED IT
THEY'RE OUT THERE ALREADY CAL
FARTHER OUT THERE ALREADY -- AND
SO THAT MAKES IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE SO I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU.
FOR TURNED OUT WE APPRECIATE AS
THE COMMITTEE IS INDICATED YOUR
BRING THE BILL FORD VERY TIMELY
VERY APPROPRIATE WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS ABOUT.
CREATING A GREATER DEGREE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY GETTING MORE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PROTECTING
THE SAFETY OF THE WORKERS AND SO --
THIS IS A ENJOYS A TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION HAS BEEN
SECONDED IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SEVERAL CALL ON THE MOTION.
THE MODE.
GIVE ME THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO I CHEN
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
AT WATER GARCIA.
MAYES [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I WORK.
QUIRK I REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
TEEN.
TING I MOTION CARRIES.
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON OKAY
WE'RE WAITING FOR OTHER AUTHORS --
SENATOR BRADFORD -- WE DO HAVE A
A BILL SB SEVENTY NELSON THAT IS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT IS THERE A
MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
SB.
SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I BURKE.
CARILLO CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GET GARCIA [inaudible]
MAYES.
THERE'S TWO G..
WHERE THIRTY AYE [inaudible]
WORK.
WHY QUIRK I REYES?
REYES I SANTIAGO.
TEEN.
TING HI [inaudible]
CONSECUTIVE ADOPTED.
HEY WE WILL LEAVE THAT AT NINE
VOTES WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- WHILE WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF A HELLO ALL JUST
QUICKLY MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT -- WITH THIS COMMITTEE YOU
TO AN ENERGY WILL HOLD TO MORE
BILL HEARINGS BEFORE SUMMER
RECESS.
BEGINS ONE NEXT WEEK ON JULY THE
THIRD IN THE FOLLOWING WEEK ON
JULY THE TENT.
AND THEN THAT'S A WRAP
.
SENATOR WILL -- HERE YOUR BILL
WELL YOU'RE.
READY TO PRESENT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
HOW WE'RE HERE?
TO HEAR YOUR PRESENTATION SENATE
BILL.
FIVE FIFTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE TODAY.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS HAD THE MOST DEADLY AND
COSTLY FIRES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
CLIMATE EXPERTS AGREE THAT WE
CAN EXPECT MORE DEVASTATING
EXTREME WILDFIRES FIRES AND
DROUGHTS ALL OF WHICH CONTRIBUTE
TO FOREST DIE OFFS.
THAT'S WHY I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT.
FIVE ONE FIVE AND NARROWLY
FOCUSED BILL THAT WOULD EXPAND
THE DEFINITION OF HIGH HAZARD
FUEL FOR BIOMASS FACILITIES WITH
BIRAM CONTRACTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN ISSUED AN
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION CALLING
FOR THE CPUC TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF EXPIRING BIOMASS
CONTRACTS.
AS PART OF THE CONCERN THAT
CALIFORNIA HAD AN ESTIMATED AT
THAT TIME IT WAS ESTIMATED AT A
HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION DEAD AND
DYING TREES.
CALIFORNIA PUT TOGETHER A MAP
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE HIGH
HAZARD ZONES IDENTIFYING AREAS
THAT COULD BE IMPACTED AS A
RESULT OF A DEAD TREE HITTING A
POWER LINE OR BLOCKING THE ROAD.
THE CPUC RESPONDED BY REQUIRING
THE UTILITIES TO PROCURE FIFTY
MEGAWATTS OF BIOMASS ENERGY.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO ACTED IN
PAST EIGHT FIFTY NINE SB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WHICH REQUIRED
ANOTHER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MEGAWATTS OF BIOMASS ENERGY
TO BE PROCURED.
IN ALL THERE ARE SEVEN CONTRACTS
SIGNED AS A RESULT OF THESE TWO
MANDATES AND THEY REFERRED TO AS
BIO RAM CONTRACTS.
ALL OF THESE CONTRACTS ARE
REQUIRED TO GET IS A SPECIFIED
AMOUNT OF FUEL FROM HIGH HAZARD
ZONES.
HOWEVER THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS REQUIREMENT
IS THAT FOREST WASTE.
THAT IS DEEMED TO BE FROM A HIGH
HAZARD ZONE NOW COST MORE THAN
FOREST WAIT WASTE THAT COULD
START A WILDFIRE.
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES PAY A
PENALTY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MEET
THE REQUIREMENT OF HIGH HAZARD
ZONE FUEL WHICH WAS AN ARBITRARY
TARGET SET AT THE ELEVENTH HOUR.
WE HAVE WE NOW KNOW WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DEAD OR DYING TREES.
AND WE HAVE AN UNHEALTHY AND
OVERSTOCK FOREST WITH EXCESS
FUEL A WILDFIRE CATASTROPHE IN
WAITING.
THE NAPA COUNTY WILDFIRES DID
NOT CONTAIN THESE HIGH HAZARD
ZONES AND NEITHER DID PARADISE.
RATHER THAN WAIT AND TELL A
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE DESTROYS A
COMMUNITY BEFORE REMOVING
REMOVING THE FUEL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO GET OUT IN
FRONT OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND TRY TO PREVENT THE NEXT
MAJOR WILDFIRE.
SB FIVE ONE FIVE EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF HIGH HAZARD ZONE
FUEL TO INCLUDE THE AREAS WITHIN
A WILDFIRE SINCE TWENTY TWELVE
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
CAL FIRE HAS ANNOUNCED EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
AS WELL AS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
CAL FIRES MAP WHICH SHOWS THESE
HAZARD HAZARD ZONES.
THIS BILL IS A SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT STEP TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS IN OUR FORESTS.
AND HELP PROTECT COMMUNITIES
FROM WILDFIRES WHERE THERE IS
EXCESS FUEL.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
MISTER CHAIR YOU AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE C. P. U. C. IS IN THE
PROCESS OF PREPARING A REPORT --
WHICH IS THE SUBJECT MATTER OF
THIS BILL WITH IT THAT REPORT
WAS TO BE.
OUT IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR AND WE
EXPECTED IT.
TO BE UTILIZED AS THE REPORT FOR
THIS BILL BUT IT'S NOW BEEN
DELAYED UNTIL JULY THIRTY FIRST
AND WE HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE
THERE'S THAT A DRAFT SOMEWHERE.
OUT WE HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THE REPORT WILL SUPPORT THE
STRATEGY IN THIS BILL -- SO WE
WE WE'D LIKE TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING SO THAT IT'S THE VEHICLE
THAT CAN IMPLEMENT -- THAT
STRATEGY -- AND IF THE REPORT
SAYS SOMETHING DIFFERENT THE
BILL CAN BE SENT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OR WE CAN MAKE
WHATEVER CHANGES WE NEED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ASSUMING IT GETS THAT FAR.
I APPRECIATE THE MOVE THIS
IMPORTANT VEHICLE.
THANK YOU.
I I DO I DO APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE WE SUPPORT WHAT THE BILL
IS TRYING TO DO BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT THE STUDY WAS OUT THERE AND
I THINK WE'RE ANTICIPATING THAT
IT.
SHOULD BE.
THE BILL OF MATERIALIZE IF NOT
WE'RE TODAY RIGHT SO WE'RE WE'RE
ALSO.
LOOKING FOR CPUC AND PGA ANY.
TO UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE IS
EXPECTING THAT THE REPORT WILL
BE MADE AVAILABLE.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE BUT
CERTAINLY BEFORE -- THE END OF A
PERIOD OF TIME TO ALLOW YOUR
BILL TO BE PROPERLY -- EVALUATED
AGAINST IT BUT I THINK ALL ALL
INDICATIONS AS YOU SAID THE
CONFORM AND IT SHOULD BE FINE
BUT WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
OF THAT IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS
OTHER WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT IT BUT WE'RE WE'RE IN
SYNC WITH THE GREAT.
THANK -- HITTING FOR OTHERS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
LET ME START BY SAYING THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION --
APPRECIATES THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR -- AND THE DISCUSSION
YOU'VE JUST HAD AROUND THE YEAR
REPORT THAT WE'RE ANTICIPATING
FOR THE UC AND BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THAT THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THE AUTHOR.
AT TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THIS
BILL ALIGNS WITH THE THAT THAT
REPORT -- THAT SEEMS TO MAKE THE
MOST SENSE.
I JUST WANT TO COMMENT BRIEFLY
ON WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
DOESN'T DO -- ONE THIS BILL DOES
NOT -- ALTER ANY EXISTING
UTILITY PURCHASE CONTRACT -- IT
DOESN'T ALTER ANY THE RULES FOR
FOR TIMBER HARVESTER CHANGER ANY
OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL RULES.
WHAT IT DOES IS IT ALLOWS US?
AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT ARE FORCED
MANAGEMENT GOALS ARE EVOLVING --
NGUYEN SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE WAS
ADOPTED ARE FORCED ISSUES WITH
THE DEAD AND DYING TREES IN THE
CENTRAL SIERRA -- TODAY OUR
ISSUES ARE NOT ONLY THOSE TREES.
BUT EFFORTS THAT WE NEED TO DO
TO FOR FIRE PREVENTION AND AND
THE REMOVAL OF TREES -- IN ORDER
TO GUARANTEE THAT OUR FORCES ARE
HEALTHY -- AND CAN RESIST FIRE --
SO BY EXPANDING -- THE
DEFINITION OF AYE HAZARD TO
INCLUDE THOSE AREAS WHERE TREES
ARE STILL LIVING.
BUT THOSE TREES ARE DESIGNATED
IN A HIGH VERY HIGH HAZARD ZONE --
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AT THAT THOSE
WILL COUNTY IN THESE BIRAM
CONTRACTS -- I THINK IT'S A
FAIRLY SIMPLE BILL -- BUT AGAIN
NOT IMPACTING EXISTING CONTRACTS --
BUT IT ALLOWS US TO PREPARE TO
MEET OUR FIRE PREVENTION GOALS
MOVING FORWARD.
BUT ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU AND
RICH GORDON FORMER MEMBER I
SHOULD OF PROPERLY INTRODUCED --
SENATOR I KNOW IT IT'S YOU IT'S
CLEAR IN OUR CONVERSATION THE
INTENT OF WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE AND HAVE IT.
DONE FOR A QUICKLY AND WE
BELIEVE THE REPORT IS IMMINENT
BUT THE REPORT HAS A AN
AMENDMENT SO WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE.
THE THE REPORT JUST HAS A DATE
IN HERE THAT IS.
PROBLEMATIC SAWFLY GET REAL
QUICK MEDIC.
AN EMAIL FROM THE C. P. U. C..
BOB TODAY AT OUR OFFICE.
ASKING WHETHER THE MENTION IN
THE REPORT OF A JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY DATE.
EXTENDED THE TIME PERIOD FOR
THAT PER PERFORATION OF THE
REPORT.
OUR ANSWER TO THEM WAS AND EQUIP
EQUIPMENT CLEAN NO THAT'S BUT
THERE WAS AT LEAST THAT
MISUNDERSTANDING OR THAT READING
OF THE OF THE OF THE ANALYSIS
AND SO I JUST WANT TO PUT IT OUT
THERE THAT -- IS NOT OUR
INTENTION TO SEE THAT I DIDN'T
BELIEVE SO AND I'M NOT SURE
WHERE THAT DATE.
CAME FROM AND SO WOULD PROBABLY
BE BEST JUST TO STRIKE THE DAY
WELL IT'S MORE OF A TECHNICAL.
ISSUES SO THAT WE JUST MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS LINE UP FOR PROBABLY
BUT WE IT IS WHERE WERE MOVING
THE BILL FORWARD BECAUSE IT
NEEDS TO MOVE IT NEEDS TO GET TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND WERE --
ANTICIPATING -- THAT THE THAT
THE STUDY WILL BE IN OUR HANDS
HERE SHORTLY SO THAT WE CAN.
EVALUATE IT BUT IT'S NOT OUR
INTENT TO SEE THIS -- DRAG ON WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO MEET YOUR
EXPECTATIONS AS WELL THAT THE
BILL THOSE FOR THIS THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT.
SO IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT I DID
YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WAS
WAITING FOR YOU SAY OKAY NOW --
OKAY NOW -- JULIE MOUNT ASK
ABOUT THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE.
WELL THIS BILL WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO THE FACILITIES THEMSELVES WE
ARE ACTUALLY HERE TODAY
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE IT
HELPS THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
TAKING FUEL FROM -- WE'RE AT
ELEVEN ON THE GROUND WITH BIO
RAM CONTRACTS FOR AROUND TWO
YEARS NOW WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE COMMUNITIES ARE PART OF
MY COMMUNITY IS A HIGH HAZARD
ZONE PARTY MIGHT COMMUNITIES OF
HI FIRE SEVERITY ZONE.
BUT WE CAN ONLY TAKE THIS TYPE
OF MATERIAL CAN'T TAKE THIS TYPE
OF MATERIAL THIS BILL WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO RESOLVING THOSE
CONFLICTS FOR THESE ROLE AND AT
RISK COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE THE
FOREST PRODUCTS INDUSTRY WHICH
ARE.
CARPENTERS MACHINISTS WOULD
WORKERS WOULDN'T POPE WORKERS
ABOUT TEN DIFFERENT UNIONS IN
THE WOOD PRODUCTS INDUSTRY.
AND ALSO ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
BILLS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT NOT
JUST ON THE FORESTRY SIDE WE IF
WE'RE GONNA ENCOURAGE THINNING
IN THESE ZONES WE NEED TO HAVE A
PLACE TO PUT THE FUEL -- ON THE
UTILITY SIDE YOU KNOW THE
UTILITIES NEED A PLACE TO PUT
THIS FUEL OTHER THAN JUST
BURNING IT OR LETTING IT DECAY
IN PILES.
AFTER THEY REMOVED AROUND THE
LINES -- I WOULD HOPE THAT AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND YOU
ALL GET YOUR ARMS AROUND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE FIRE PACKAGE IS
GONNA LOOK LIKE -- BEFORE THE
END OF THE YEAR THAT YOU
CONSIDER ACTUALLY EXPANDING THIS
BILL TOUCHES HIGH FIRE RISK
ZONES.
VIC NOT JUST VERY HIGH
FIRESTONE'S BUT ALSO HI FIRE
RISK SONS.
CERTAINLY ALL OF YOU REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE HIGH FIRE
RISKS -- OWNS -- SO WE WOULD
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I WILL HERE JUST -- ADD ONS TO
SUPPORT.
SURE JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC ON
BEHALF OF THE ROLE COUNTIES
ASSOCIATE IN MY COMMENTS WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN MADE
THESE FACILITIES ARE ABSOLUTELY
VITAL. FOR FIRE RISK REDUCTION
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY THE BILL IS INTENDED
TO PROVIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHEN MEMBERS
DEREK OFTEN HAVE LEE CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO REMEMBERS
VINCENT WHAT MODEL WITH THE
WHITE IN A GROUP ON BEHALF OF I
TRY POWER SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRIS
MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ELLERY NEAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
JULIE HALL WITH SO STATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE
TO SPEAK OR TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE I WILL TURN BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS DR.
I JUST A COMMENT THAT JUST THANK
YOU FOR THE SPELL I WAS UP IN UP
IN THE HIGH SIERRAS TO TWO WEEKS
AGO AND DISMOUNTED TREE STILL
PILED UP IN MASSIVE PILES THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST HEADING TO
BE BURNED OR JUST TO QUE RIGHT
THERE.
IS INCREDIBLE -- AND TO BE ABLE
TO NOT GET CAUGHT UP IN THE
DETAILS OF WHICH ZONE IN WHICH
SIZE TREE BUT TO BE ABLE TO SAY
WE HAVE A PROBLEM THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS.
AND WHILE WE ALL WANT TO MOVE AT
SOME POINT TO HOW 2% LECTURE
VACATION WE ARE NOWHERE NEAR
THAT YET AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
AN ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH.
AS A GROUP FOR DIVORCE WASTE AND
THEN ALSO AG WASTE MEANT AND AND
IF WE CAN'T KEEP THAT BY MUST
FACILITIES RUNNING AND THEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE SET THE THE
CAPACITY WHEN FIRES COME TO BE
ABLE TO PULL THE TREES OUT AND
DO SOMETHING WITH IT SO IT'S A
BIG.
COMPREHENSIVE ISSUE AND I'M GLAD
YOU'RE WORKING ON THINK YOU'RE
MUCH.
THANK YOU SQUARE SEARCHING --
SERVER I'M NOT.
UP -- LOOKING AT THE THE LETTER
OF OPPOSITION FROM THE SIERRA
CLUB IN THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE MAKING THE
ARGUMENT THAT [inaudible]
TO WHILE THE THE THEY HAVE A
POLLUTION I AM QUOTING FROM
THEIR LETTER THE HEAVY POLLUTION
A HIGH COST OF THE BY MASS INTO
INCINERATORS WERE JUSTIFIED BY A
PERCEIVED NEED TO REMOVE AND
DISPOSE OF TREES THAT POSE A
HIGH RISK TO COMMUNITIES -- BUT
THEY THEY MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
BASED ON THE ECONOMICS OF BY
MASS.
INCINERATION THAT.
TO THAT -- THE THE TREES WOULD
ONLY BE TAKEN FROM THE CHEAPEST
THERE IS NOT THERE IS THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS THE HIGHEST.
FIRE RISK COULD YOU RESPOND TO
THOSE -- ARGUMENTS.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION REALLY
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH THAT THE
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO
INCLUDE -- BIO MAT MASS WASTE
MATERIAL THAT IS -- THAT IS A
HAZARD TO COMMUNITIES AND SO
IT'S NOT THAT IT'S CHEAPER IT'S
THAT IT IT IS -- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES ONE IS SOME OF
IT IS JUST LYING AROUND AND IT
IS -- IT'S A DANGER TO THE
COMMUNITY FRANKLY THE WAY IT'S
BEING DISPOSED OF RIGHT NOW IS
TO LET IT BIO DEGRADE WHICH IS --
EMITTING A LOT OF CARBON -- THE
DECOMPOSITION RELEASES CARBON
AND AND IS NOT GOOD BUT BUT EVEN
MORE DANGEROUS IS THAT BECAUSE
IT IS FUEL IF IT LIGHTS UP.
IT -- THE POLLUTION THAT'S
CREATED BY THE BURNING MATERIAL
IS -- EVEN WORSE AT IT APART
FROMTHE FACT THAT WOULD THEN
EVERYBODY BREATHE BREATHE IT IN
RIGHT NOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
MANY OF OUR OUR REGIONS IS THAT --
IN PARTICULAR AGRICULTURAL WASTE
IS BURNT IT'S JUST BURNED IN THE
FEEL THERE'S NO PLACE TO PUT IT
AND THERE'S IT'S IT YOU'RE NOT
GENERATING ANY ENERGY.
WHEN YOU'RE BURNING WASTE IN A
IN THE MIDDLE OF AN AGRICULTURAL
FIELDS YOU MIGHT AS WELL TAKE IT
TO A BIO MASS FACILITY?
BURN IT CLEANLY.
AND AND AND THEY'VE ALL BEEN IT
RETROFITTED WITH THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF OF THEIR THEIR
SCRUBBERS THAT THAT CLEAN THAT
THE BY PRODUCT AND SO -- THIS
WILL NOT ALLOW.
CHEAPER MATERIAL.
THAT IS NOT A DANGER TO THE
COMMUNITY TO BE UTILIZED THIS IS
THIS IS MATERIAL THAT IS
CREATING A HUGE PUBLIC SAFETY
CRISIS AND AND WE'VE VERY
CAREFULLY THAT THE THE BILL WAS
ACTUALLY BIGGER WE THINK IT
SHOULD BE BAKER -- WE'VE
NARROWLY TAILORED IT AT THE
REQUEST OF SENATE COMMITTEES --
TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE HIGHEST
NEED AREA BUT I WOULD NOT BE
SURPRISED IF THE REPORT THAT
COMES OUT FROM THE C. P. U. C.
SAYS WE NEED TO BROADEN IT A
LITTLE BIT -- BECAUSE WE HAVE A
ON DOES NOT A VERY SPECIFIC
LEGAL TERM BUT WE HAVE A TON OF
MATERIAL OUT THERE THAT NEEDS TO
BE DISPOSED OF AND THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GONNA GET RID OF IT IS IF
WE CAN WE WE HAVE A USE -- AND
WE CAN WE CAN MOVE IT -- QUICKLY
AND USE AND USE IT TO CREATE
ENERGY.
SO I I I FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE
WITH WITH WITH THAT PREMISE IN
THAT BUT BUT LET ME ALSO SAY
THAT I HAD EARLY CONVERSATION
WHEN I GOT TO THE ASSEMBLY --
TWO YEARS AGO AND I ASKED THE
SIERRA CLUB WHAT'S YOUR SOLUTION
TO THE HUNDRED AND TWO DEAD OR
DYING TREES AND BASICALLY WHAT
THEY TELL ME IS LEAVE IT.
LEAVE IT ON THE GROUND AND I WAS
APPALLED BECAUSE DECOMPOSITION
IS NOT THE SOLUTION -- FOR FOR
THIS THIS MATERIAL AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT WITH THE THE
CHALLENGES WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT ARE FIRES ARE BURNING
HOTTER THEY'RE THEY'RE MOVING A
LOT FASTER.
AND THIS MATERIAL LAYING AROUND
OR AND A LOT OF IT IS IS.
IT IT'S PEOPLE REALLY DO NEED TO
GO UP INTO THE HIGH SIERRAS AND
SEE THE DEAD TREES UP THERE IT'S
APPALLING.
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO TAKE THOSE
TREES OUT WE NEED TO GET RID OF
THEM AND WE NEED TO RE PLANNING
ON THE WAY YOU DO THAT IS IF
YOU'VE GOT A A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THE FUEL THAT CREATES.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT SO I
I DISAGREE WITH THAT THERE THERE
IS STATEMENT OKAY.
I MEAN THAT THAT MAY BE THE
BOTTOM LINE THE THAT.
TO YOU DO YOU DISAGREE WITH WITH
THEIR STATEMENTS I YOU KNOW I I
IT DID HAVE THE BENEFIT ARE
GOING UP IN THE HIGH SIERRAS --
WITH WITH THE TOUR THEREFORE SHE
ASSOCIATION THAT WAS LED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER -- RECENTLY AND
IN A WHILE I AGREE COMPLETE WITH
WITH YOU KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'RE SAYING IT JUST MAKES
COMMON SENSE THAT IF YOU WANT TO
FIGHT THE THE WITH THE WILD
FIRES.
WE NEED TO CLEAR OUT THE FUEL
ARM AND AND AND WE NEED
[inaudible]
TO PROVIDE THE YOU KNOW MARKET
AND OTHER INCENTIVES TO A TO
DECLARE THAT FUEL.
IT JUST BOTHERS ME THAT -- YOU
KNOW.
I MEAN.
YOU KNOW I AND AGAIN I'M QUOTING
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB AND AND A
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
LETTER HERE THAT -- THEY'RE
CLAIMING THAT THAT THE THE
PROGRAM THE BIRAM PROGRAM HAS
JUST IS NOT FILLED ITS.
ITS PURPOSE OF HELPING THE
REMOVING UTILIZE TREES THAT POSE
HAZARDS -- SO YEAH IT LOOKS LIKE
A MAYBE I NEED TO HAVE I I WISH
THE SIERRA CLUB HERE TO ADDRESS
THIS BUT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE NOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OCTOBER.
WELL I I DON'T BELIEVE THERE
LETTER -- COULD YOU MAKE ME CO
AUTHOR.
I WELL YES IF YOU READ THEIR
LETTER.
IT SAYS -- WELL WE SHOULD ONLY
BE WORRIED ABOUT TREES THAT ARE
NEAR HOMES HAVEN'T THEY SEEN
PARADISE PARADISE.
WHEN UP WHEN MILES AWAY A FIRE
STARTED AND THEN IT WASN'T SO
MUCH THAT THE FIRE WENT THROUGH
PARADISE IT'S THAT THE BURNING
EMBERS WERE BLOWN BY HUNDRED
MILE AN HOUR WINDS?
I SHOULD NEVER BEEN BELT.
FRANKLY IT SHOULD NEVER BE
REBUILT.
FROM THE EIGHTIES THEY KNEW THAT
WAS GOING TO BE DISASTER BUT AT
ANY RATE.
THAT'S A SEPARATE SUBJECT THE
POINT IS THE FIRE DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE TO BE NEAR YOUR HOUSE TO
BURN IT DOWN.
THE EMBERS COMING IN THESE HIGH
WINDS CAN BURN YOUR HOUSE DOWN
YOU CAN CLEAR EVERY TREE AND IN
FACT IF YOU GO THROUGH PARADISE
THEIR PLACES WHERE THE TREES ARE
THERE BUT THE HOUSES BURNED DOWN.
SO -- THIS LETTER IS -- IT
MISSES THE POINT.
OTHER THAN THAT IS JUST FINE I
HAVE ONE QUESTION -- I DO HAVE
ONE OTHER QUESTION WHICH IS
[inaudible]
SO ARE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY BEFORE I
WENT ON TO THE SENATE.
HE WAS ALWAYS PRESSING US TO DO
MORE OF THIS IN THE BILL SEMINAR
THAT WOULD GET OUT OF HERE BUT
THEY DIE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THANK GOD WE'VE.
WELL WE DIDN'T LISTEN TO HIM
SOON ENOUGH BUT AT LEAST WE'RE
DOING IT NOW.
MY CONCERN IS THOUGH A LOT OF
THESE PLANTS HAVE SHUT DOWN.
THE CCA'S ARE PROBABLY NOT GOING --
TO CONTRACT WITH THEM FOR
ELECTRICITY AND AND P. GENIE IS
MAYBE.
THEY ALWAYS USED TO BE THE ONE
OF CONTRACTED BUT THEY'VE LOST
MOST OF THEIR CUSTOMERS.
HOW WE GOING TO ACTUALLY --
BRING SOME OF THESE PLANTS BACK
BECAUSE THERE'S INADEQUATE
CAPACITY GIVEN THAT THESE SHUT
DOWN AND HOW WE WERE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTS.
GEN TWO WEB ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE WITHIN A MEETING YESTERDAY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE JUST ON
THIS TOPIC -- TERMS OF THE YOU
KNOW WHAT DO WE DO MOVING
FORWARD LAST YEAR IN THE IN SB
NOT A ONE THE LEGISLATURE DID
EXTEND -- CONTRACTS -- FOR BIRAM
BUT FOR FIVE YEARS -- BUT YOU
NEED A LONG TERM CONTRACT
COMMITMENT -- AND OUR FORCE
MANAGEMENT ISSUES ARE GOING TO
BE LONG TERM.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING GOING TO
SOLVE ANY YEAR -- TO THIS IS A
LONG TERM PROJECT BECAUSE WE'VE
WE'VE GOT TO THIS SITUATION --
OVER CENTURY -- IN TERMS OF THE
ARE FORCE MANAGEMENT STYLE -- SO --
WE'D WILL NEED TO LOOK AT YOU
LONGER TERM CONTRACTS --
EXTENDING IT ADDITIONAL --
RESOURCES TO HELP MOVE FORWARD
ADDITIONAL -- FACILITIES AND AND
TO MAINTAIN FACILITIES WE HAVE A
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES -- YOU
KNOW OPERATE ON A VERY THIN
MARGIN YEAH AND I THINK -- AS IT
RELATES TO THE CCA'S -- YOU KNOW
IT WOULD THEIR DO NEED TO BE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THIS IS A
RENEWABLE ENERGY -- IN THE YOU
KNOW NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
I THINK.
SO THIS IS CLEARLY A PROJECT FOR
ANOTHER DAY BUT IT'S ONE THAT.
I'D BE GLAD TO START THINKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
IDEAS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH REST.
I WASN'T GOING TO ADD ANYTHING
BUT I THINK THAT I DO WANT TO
RESPOND I THINK.
WHEN THE SIERRA CLUB DOES
PROVIDE THEIR INPUT IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THERE ARE
ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT?
AND I THINK THEIR INPUT. FOR ME
ESPECIALLY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT I THINK THAT -- THE
AUTHOR HAS CONSIDERED THAT A BIO
MOUSE -- THIS ISN'T IT.
THE CLEANEST WAYS TO TO GET
ENERGY THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE SO
EVERYTHING THAT IS BEING SAID BY
THIS YEAR CLUB IS ACCURATE.
I THINK THAT WE ARE IN VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES -- IT IT ISN'T
UNTIL LAST YEAR THAT I WOULD
EVEN CONSIDER BIOMASS QUITE
FRANKLY.
AND WE HAD THE THE CONVERSATION
LAST YEAR.
BUT I THINK THAT THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES SO WE DO
HAVE TO LOOK AT SOMETHING BEYOND
WHAT WE'VE LOOKED AT BEFORE.
BUT EVEN HAVING SAID THAT I I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE INPUT
FROM SIERRA CLUB BECAUSE THESE
ARE.
WHAT THEY SUGGESTED WHAT THEY
TELL US ARE ARE THE VERY THINGS
WE NEED TO CONSIDER WHEN WE'RE
MAKING DECISIONS WE CANNOT?
WE CANNOT JUST THINK OF ONE AREA
SAY THIS IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT AND THAT'S THE END OF IT
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE WHO SPEAK
AGAINST.
A PARTICULAR PATH SO THAT WE CAN
THEN THINK THROUGH EXACTLY WHAT
IT IS WE WANT TO DO AND IF NEED
BE THEN RETHINK AT THE WE THINK
IT THROUGH.
SO THAT WEEK ALWAYS LOOK FOR THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE TO GET TO
WHERE WE WANT.
DURING THEIR THESE EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR POINT WELL
TAKEN.
IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- I'VE WRITTEN IT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE A CONVERSATION --
AND I I AM.
I THINK THE CHALLENGES IS THESE
THESE ARE DIFFICULT TIMES -- AND
AS WE LOOK AT OUR ENERGY
PRODUCTION -- WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO THINK A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE
THE BOX AT TIMES BECAUSE THE
POSSIBILITY OF WILDFIRES CAUSED
BY ELECTRICAL LINES MEANS WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL WERE PUTTING
THOSE ELECTRICAL LINES.
AND AND AND AS WE LOOK AT THAT
WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ENERGY WHEN WE
NEED IT -- SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ROLLING BLACKOUTS SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE -- ENERGY SHORTAGES --
AND SO THAT WE HAVE AN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO PICK THE
CLEANEST IN THAT AND THE BEST
USE OF OF A OF A OF A OF THE
TOOLS IN ONE OF THE TOOLS.
UNFORTUNATELY IS IS DEAD AND
DYING TREES ISSUE -- WE NEED A
CLEAR AND WE NEED TO CLEAN THAT
UP AND AND THAT'S THE REASON
THAT I'M HERE TODAY TO WHAT I
WISH THAT THEY THAT THOSE TREES
WERE WERE NOT THERE ABSOLUTELY --
BECAUSE WEEK THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS TO TO GET ENERGY AND AND
WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON THAT BUT
BUT THIS IS A A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR OUR
ENTIRE STATE BECAUSE IT'S THE
TOURIST SEASON AND PEOPLE ARE
TRAVELING AND THEY'RE VISITING
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SAFE WHEN THEY'RE THERE
AND SO THAT WE CAN CLEAR WHAT --
WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN DETERMINED BY
CAL FIRE TO BE HIGH HAZARD -- IF
YOU WILL AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK AND AND DISCUSS -- WAYS TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO TO GET RID OF THIS FUEL AND
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC SO I THINK
YOU FOR FOR FOR YOUR ATTENTION
TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WELL WE DO APPRECIATE --
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
WE APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU?
OF WE HAVE A MOTION -- IT'S DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE FIFTEEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AT THE MENTION NATURAL
RESOURCES HOLDEN BY HOLDEN AYE
PATTERSON AYE PATTERSON AYE
BURKE.
CODY ALL CARILLO LIFE CHEN.
GEN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
QUIRK HI.
BURKE I RAY RAY S. [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
TEEN.
YOU HAVE NINE VOTES THE BILL IS
OUT WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SENATOR BRADFORD IS OUR GLASS
AUTHOR FOR THE DAY WE HAVE --
HAS BE ONE FIFTY FIVE WHICH WILL
HEAR FROM YOU FIRST ON AND THEN
SENATE BILL.
TWO FIFTY FIVE WELCOME THANK YOU.
THE BILL THANK YOU.
I CHECKED LAST RIVAL.
ROBOT WITH THAT IF -- ALL RIGHT
ALL RIGHT WELL IT'S JUST SIMPLY
AS BE ONE FIVE FIVE SIMPLY --
MEASURES.
AND IMPROVED TO EXISTING --
STATING YOU PROGRAMS INCREASING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BOTH BOTH THE
R. P. R. P. S. AND I. R. P..
AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
RELIABILITY IN THIS BILL HELPS
US GET THERE SO I HAVE TO
WITNESSES IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
ADD SOMETHING WE HAVE -- SCOTT
WHICH WHAT'S IN CALIFORNIA I'M A
WITH THE ALICIA FOR CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES AND WE HAVE CALLING A
CUSHY FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT
WHICH ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE.
BILL THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED TWO
VERY IMPORTANT PIECES OF POLICY
ONE WAS THE OUR PS WHICH YOU'VE
INCREASED. THREE TIMES -- IN
RECENT YEARS AND TO THE
REQUIREMENT IN SB THREE FIFTY
THAT ALL RETAIL SELLERS -- PUT
TOGETHER AN INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLAN.
ALL THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES IS
MAKE SURE THAT.
THE P. YOU SEE ENFORCES THE LAWS
THAT YOU ALL PASSED.
AND THE FIRST PROVISION WHICH
REQUIRES THAT THEY REVIEW ALL
RETAIL SELLERS -- ANNUAL
COMPLIANCE REPORTS WITH THE OUR
PS AND IF THE CPUC FLAGS A
PATTERN THAT.
CONCERNS THEM THAT PERHAPS.
AND I OWE YOU OR E. S. P. OR CCA
IS NOT ON TRACK TO MEET THEIR
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT THEY SIMPLY MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEM AS TO
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO IN ORDER TO
COMPLY.
SO FOR ANYBODY TO COME UP WITH
OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY THEY'RE
OPPOSING IT FOR ONE REASON AND
ONE REASON ONLY AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO CPUC
TO SAY THAT THE EMPEROR HAS NO
CLOTHES.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF NAKED EMPERORS OUT THERE SO
WE'D VIRGIN I'VE A VERY COLORFUL.
YEAH.
HELLO COMMITTEE UP MY NAME'S
CAUCUS NAY ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S ON CALIFORNIA'S AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR POWER SUPPLY
OPERATIONS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB -- ONE
FIFTY FIVE AS YOU ALL KNOW.
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY -- A
DISHES -- AGREEMENT A CLEAN
ENERGY GOAL 60% OUR PS BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND A 100% CLEAN ENERGY
BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IN ORDER TO
GET THERE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR ELECTRIC SYSTEM IS
RELIABLY PLAN -- FOR AND THAT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE THAT EACH LOAD
SERVING ANTI -- BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO DO IT'S IT'S PRO
RATA SHARE OF THE RELIABILITY
AND CLEAN ENERGY THAT -- IS
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO IT TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
SB ONE FIFTY FIVE MAKES CLEAR.
THAT THE CPC IS THAT ENTITY THAT
WILL PROVIDE CENTRAL PLANNING
AND OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
ELLIS THESE MEET THEIR RID CLEAN
ENERGY AND THE LIABILITY GOALS.
OF THE ELECTRIC GRID IS A VERY
COMPLICATED -- DYNAMIC SYSTEM
AND IT IT WOULD BE -- QUITE
FRANKLY -- VERY DAMAGING TO OUR
ECONOMIC SUCCESS AS A STATE IF
WE ALLOW CERTAIN LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES TO NOT HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A COLLECTIVE
PLANNING PROCESS TO ENSURE THE
GREATEST RELIABLE.
OF WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS VERY WELL
INTENDED LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
SITUATED -- TO BE A STATEWIDE
ENERGY GRID PLANNER.
LIKEWISE WITH ENERGY SERVICE
PROVIDERS THEIR THEIR MOTIVE
UNDERSTANDABLY IS TO PROVIDE
POWER AT THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
COST TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO MEET
THEIR RELIABILITY AND THEIR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AT THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE COST BUT THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE COST MAY NOT ACTUALLY
ENSURE RELIABILITY.
BECAUSE OF THE INTERMITTENT HR
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY.
ON SOLD ONLY PRODUCES WHEN THE
SUN SHINES WIND ONLY PRODUCES
WHEN THE WIND BLOWS.
OUR HYDRO IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
PRECIPITATION THAT WE GET THAT
YEAR.
WE NEED TO CAREFULLY AND AND AND
AND VERY THOUGHTFULLY PLANNED
HOW TO BRING ALL THESE RESOURCES
TOGETHER WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
100% CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
AND THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE ALL
LOAD SERVING EIGHTIES TO SUBJECT
THEMSELVES TO A A CENTRAL
OVERSIGHT -- TO MAKE SURE WE GET
THERE SO WITH THAT IN MIND I I
URGE YOU ALL -- TO TO VOTE I ON
SB ONE FIFTY FIVE AND I WILL
STATE YOUR PRESENT QUESTIONS.
PROJECT THAT THERE ANYONE HERE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
YES MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HUNTER STERN AYE BE DEBBIE
TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ALLISON BROWN I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY AREA ACTION SAN DIEGO
THREE FIFTY SOUTH A LOS ANGELES
THREE FIFTY CLIMATE ACTION GROUP.
SO CAL THREE FIFTY CLIMATE
ACTION THREE FIFTY VENTURA
COUNTY CRIME AND HAVE AND THE
THREE FIFTY RIVERSIDE.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WILL RECEIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DON GILBERT FOR CAL
CCA WE OPPOSE.
I WANTED TO FIRST ACTUALLY
APOLOGIZED TO SENATOR BRADFORD
WE THE BILL WAS SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPROVED AND SENATE ENERGY WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AND THERE WAS A LITTLE CONFUSION
OR MISUNDERSTANDING NOBODY'S
FAULT -- ABOUT ONE PROVISION
WHICH IS THE PROVISION LEFT THAT
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
TODAY AND WE THOUGHT THAT WAS
OUT OF THE BILL AND SO WE HAD
REMOVED OPPOSITION THAT
COMMITTEE SO I'M SORRY FOR THE
MISUNDERSTANDING -- SO WE HAVE
TWO CONCERNS FIRST THE ONE I
JUST REFERENCE WHICH IS ABOUT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
THAT INSERTS THE WORD IN FORCE
WHICH DOESN'T EXISTING CURRENT
LAW IN TERMS OF THE CPC'S
AUTHORITY.
OVER THE I. R. P. WE WE THINK
THAT -- THAT'S AN EXPANSION OF
THE CDC'S SPECIFIC CUT -- WRITES
A OUR POWER AND THE I. R. P. IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A PLANNING
DOCUMENT IT'S NOT A ROCK SOLID
PROCUREMENT PLAN THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE FLEXIBILITY. TEN
TWELVE YEARS OUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES COULD BE DIFFERENT
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE LOCKED IN
THAT COULD.
CAUSE RATES TO GO UP AND OTHER
PROBLEMS SO -- SO WE THINK THAT
BY INSERTING THE WORD AND FORCE
IT GIVES A CBC THE ABILITY. TO
NULLIFY CONTRACTS AND SO ON AND
THAT'S AN ABILITY THAT WE DON'T
THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE WITH
REGARD TO CCA'S -- THE SECOND
REASON OUR SECOND CONCERN.
WHICH I WHICH I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CONCERN IS THE
FOLLOWING.
SB THREE FIFTY ESTABLISHED THIS
FIRST OF A KIND STATEWIDE IRP
PROCESS THAT BILL IS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IT WAS.
VERY INTENSELY NEGOTIATED
INCLUDING BY THE BY THE CCA
WORLD -- IT BECAME EFFECTIVE LAW
OBVIOUSLY ON JANUARY ONE SIXTEEN
WORD NOW IN THE MIDST ROUGHLY
HALF WAY THROUGH THE FIRST
STATEWIDE IRP PROCESS EVER AT
THE CPUC.
THIS IS AKIN TO BEING IN THE MET
IN THE MIDDLE OF PENDING
LITIGATION WITH A BILL COMING TO
THE LEGISLATURE. TO IMPACT THE
SUBJECT OF THE LITIGATION AND
GENERALLY AS YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE LIKES TO HOLD OFF TO
SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE LITIGATION.
WE THINK THAT'S THE SITUATION
HERE -- WE EXPECT A AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE ABOUT HALFWAY
THROUGH THIS EXISTING PROCEEDING
BASED ON A STATUTE THAT WENT
INTO LAW A FEW YEARS AGO.
WE EXPECT THE FINAL A PROPOSED
FINAL ORDER IN LATE TWENTY
TWENTY OR EARLY TO TWENTY ONE
AND A FINAL ORDER CAN BE AS
EARLY AS THIRTY DAYS AFTER THAT
FOR LATER.
SO WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD WAIT FOR THIS FIRST I OUR
P. BASED ON THE EXISTING LAW TO
BE COMPLETED.
I REPEAT PROCESS AND THEN BRING
IN THE CPC TO AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BRING AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS LET'S SEE WHAT WAS
RIGHT AND WRONG IF THEY'RE AND
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE.
BUT DON'T DO THAT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PRECEDING.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW I MEAN THEY ARE THE AUTHOR
MAY HAVE MAY HAVE A VALID POINT
MAYBE THIS CHANGE SHOULD SHOULD
SHOULD HAPPEN A LOT BUT MAYBE
NOT.
LET'S WAIT AND FINISH AND THEN
SEE WE THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE PRUDENT AND FRANKLY THE
RIGHT WAY TO PROCEED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE.
TO AT THEIR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
BRANDENBURG REPRESENTING CINEMA
CLEAN POWER LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS BY MISTER GILBERT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALICIA **** ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOSE CLEAN ENERGY IN OPPOSITION.
VINCENT WERE OF MUCH OF THE HALF
OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY IN
OPPOSITION.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR NEED
ASSOCIATES FOR SILICON VALLEY
CLEAN ENERGY IN OPPOSITION.
MARK SPENCER MAKER FOR PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY INVALID CLEAN
ENERGY IN OPPOSITION.
CAROL SOMEBODY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY SELAMA BEATS LANA ENERGY
LANDS.
EMILY PAPPAS SOME HAVE MC IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
WILL TURN TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR THE CLERK --
SO THE WAY I READ YOUR BILL --
DEEP WELL FIRST OF ALL THE
QUESTION ABOUT ENFORCE
REQUIREMENT VERSUS.
REQUIRES A CONDITION OF APPROVAL
OR CERTIFICATION.
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
THAT LANGUAGE YET NOW THAT'S THE
FIRST -- HEARD THAT THAT'S A
CONCERN.
WHILE BE MORE APT TO EXAMINE A
BETTER I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
ISSUE THAT MISTER GOVERNMENT CAN
ALWAYS ISSUE IS THAT
[inaudible]
I'LL.
P. C. C. H. DO NOT THANK.
FAT WELL.
AND YOU CAN DISAGREE WITH ME
HERE THEY DO NOT THINK THAT THE
P. YOU SEE HAS AUTHORITY OVER
THEM.
IS THAT WHAT IT COMES DOWN.
TO NO WE THINK THAT THEY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY SET FORTH IN SB
THREE FIFTY WHICH IS TO CERTIFY.
R. I. R. PEAS AS OPPOSED TO A
PROVE THE I. R. PEAS OF THE I.
O. U.'S.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
EXPANDED IN TOWER AND LET'S SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE'RE SO IN
THE CURRENT EXISTING PROCEED
PROCEEDING SO WHAT JUST
COMPLETED A PRIZED OPPOSED TO
APPROVED ME.
IF IF YOU THIS GIVES ME WHAT.
WHAT THE CERTIFIED SUPPOSED TO
BE APPROVED MAIN?
WELL HONESTLY AT THE THIS IS A
VERY NEW WANTS ISSUE WHICH IS
WHY IT DEPENDS WHO YOU TALK.
TO YOU KNOW MISTER WEST WILL
HAVE ONE VIEW WILL HAVE ANOTHER
OTHERS WILL HAVE OTHERS BUT ONE
THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL
IT'S THAT WAS IN THIS PROCESS
WHERE THEY USED A DIFFERENT
DESCRIPTOR OF THE RIGHTS OF THE
AUTHORITY OF THE CPC OVER THE I.
O. U.'S VERSES OVER THE CCA'S
AND WE THINK THIS.
THIS -- LANGUAGE WOULD MOVE
TOWARDS WHAT.
THE CPC AUTHORITY IS OVER THE I.
O. USE RIGHT NOW AND AND THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE THE WAY TO GO
BUT LET'S FINISH THE PROCEEDING
AND IF THE AUTHOR HAS RECEIVED
INFORMATION THAT THE PROCEEDINGS
OVER THAT'S THAT'S AN ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
RIGHT SO MY CONCERN HAS ALWAYS
BEEN WHEN YOU HAVE MANY SMALL
ENTITIES
HOW THE HECK DO YOU -- BALLOTS
THE GRANT.
THAT'S THE ISSUE HERE AND YOU
CAN'T HAVE.
YOU NO ONE SMALL CCA AND ANOTHER
SMALL CCA AND ANOTHER.
ONE REALLY BALANCING YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A CENTRAL AUTHORITY LOOKING
AT THIS.
WHICH SHOULD BE THE I SO AND
THEN THE OUT WITH THAT
INFORMATION THE P. YOU SEE. FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE LATEST --
STATEMENT OF WHERE AND WHAT THE
SEE THE ARM.
CCA'S WOULD DO.
DAY PROCURED A WHOLE LOT OF
SOLAR BECAUSE IT IS THE CHEAPEST
THING AND THEY PROMISE LOWER
PRICES.
BUT IT'S NOT A BALANCED
PORTFOLIO IT WOULD NEVER BE ABLE
TO WORK IN REALITY.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
THE CASE AND AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
THAT CENTRAL LOOK THAT CENTRAL
AUTHORITY.
AND THREE FIFTY DIDN'T DETERMINE
EVERYTHING I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US NOW TO LOOK AT
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ALL
FIT [inaudible]
AND IF THE IF WE DON'T.
WE COULD HAVE BLACKOUTS.
CONSUMER CITY.
THANK YOU I WOULD AGREE WITH THE
WITH -- MISTER QUIRK IN.
THE NEED FOR A CENTRAL AUTHORITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BALANCING -- ALL OF OUR CALYCES
TO TO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE NOT
ALL HAVE ADEQUATE BUT RELIABLE --
ENERGY -- BUT IF IT APPEARS TO
ME I AM REFERRING TO THE CAL CCA
LETTER AND MISTER GILBERT I LIKE
TO ASK FOR CLARIFICATION.
YOUR LETTER DATED JUNE FOURTH OF
OF A TWENTY NINETEEN IT IT IT
PROPOSES AMENDMENTS THAT.
SEEMS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
TO THAT -- THE PC SHOULD.
EXECUTE THE IT'S R. P. MANDATE
UNDER SB THREE FIFTY IS THAT
CORRECT.
YEAH THAT THAT'S CORRECT WE WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH MR QUIRK
EITHER THAT SHOULD THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A CENTRAL ENTITY
THAT'S TAKEN A LOOK THE QUESTION
IS WHAT IS THEIR AUTHORITY.
WE DON'T THINK BUT LET'S LET
THIS FIRST I OUR P. STATEWIDE R.
P. EVER SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE
BILL BE COMPLETED BEFORE WE DO
THE LOOK BACK AND DECIDE WHAT IF
ANYTHING NEEDS TO BE CHANGED IN
STATUTE.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE SAYING BUT WE
AGREE FUNDAMENTAL WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL POINT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK OKAY AND AND ALONG
THOSE LINES.
YOUR PROPOSED AMENDMENT.
TO IS -- TO REQUIRE -- THE LLC'S
TO TO FILE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANS AND A SCHEDULE FOR PURE AT
PERIODIC UPDATES TO THE PLAN --
THAT THAT'S YOUR FIRST PROPOSED
AMENDMENT.
CORRECT AND AND HAS SAID AMENDED
AND BEEN ACCEPTED.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE OKAY AND
THEN THE SECOND A PROPOSED
AMENDMENT.
IS FOR THE THAT THE PC.
SHALL REQUIRE AS A CONDITION OF
APPROVAL OR CERTIFICATION.
THAT THE I. R. P. OF EACH LSE
CONTRIBUTES TO DIVERSE IMBALANCE
BEFORE PART FULL AND I I HAVE TO
ADMIT.
MISTER GILBERT I I I I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN.
BETWEEN SHALL ENFORCE THE
REQUIREMENT AND SHALL REQUIRE AS
A CONDITION OF APPROVAL OF
CERTIFICATION COULD.
TO ENLIGHTEN US ON THAT -- YEAH
SO.
FAIR QUESTION AND THAT'S WHY I
SAID IT'S THE NEW ONCE ISSUE
WITH THIS LANGUAGE.
OUR ATTORNEYS BELIEVE THE
INSERTION OF THE WORLD WORD
[inaudible]
AND FORCE [inaudible]
SUBSTANTIALLY.
INCREASES THE AUTHORITY OF THE
CPC ON THESE ISSUES CHANGES THE
AUTHORITY OVER THE CCA'S WHICH
YOU KNOW ARE AFTER ALL
INDEPENDENT BROKERS.
AND BUT WE AGREED BUT WE
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE NEED FOR
THIS CENTRAL BODY TAKING A LOOK.
SO THE LANGUAGE WE WE PROPOSE
ACCORDING TO OUR ATTORNEYS.
YOU KNOW IS MORE CONSISTENT WITH
SB THREE FIFTY THAT POINT YOUR
YOUR MAIN CONCERN IS.
AS INDICATE IN YOUR LETTER THAT --
YOUR YOUR CONCERN THAT CENTER
BRADFORD'S BILL IS CONVERTING
OUR PIECE FROM A PLANNING
DOCUMENT TO PROCUREMENT MANDATES.
YEAH I MEAN THAT THAT'S WHAT I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY THAT'S
A MAJOR CONCERN THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
IN CEMENT.
AND AND IN FACT -- ALONG THOSE
LINES I MEAN I I I NOTED THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TALKED
ABOUT HOW [inaudible]
THE THE ENERGY PROCUREMENT --
TODAY -- ALL IS -- IS IS VASTLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE FROM DAY FROM
THE GENERATION THAT WE RELIED ON
A DECADE AGO AND SO THAT WOULD
HIGHLIGHT YOUR CONCERN ABOUT.
LOCKING OURSELVES INTO THESE
LONG TERM KIND.
TRAXXAS ACCURATE LOCKING IT
LOCKING US INTO -- ONE PLANNING
CONVERTING A PLANNING DOCUMENT
TO A ROCK SOLID YOU KNOW
DOCUMENT THAT THAT HAS NO
FLEXIBILITY THAT WOULD BE THE
CONCERNED YES.
I I'D LIKE TO DID TURN -- TO THE
ADDISON REPRESENTATIVE -- WE WE
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THE I. R.
P. SHOULD BE.
YOU KNOW HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY
TO ALLOW FOR FOR THE THAT THE
CHANGING -- ENERGY TECHNOLOGY.
YES THERE ARE PEAS ACTUALLY DO
PROVIDE A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY AND GIVES A LITTLE
BIT OF A A CONFUSION HERE --
UTILITY -- ARE PEAS -- WITH --
AND LONG TERM RETIREMENT PLANS
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THEM -- WHAT THE
CQC DOES IS IT SETS STANDARDS
THAT THE UTILITY HAS TO ME IN
THIS CASE -- UNDER A SB ONE
FIFTY FIVE THE EXPECTATION WOULD
BE THAT THE CPC WOULD APPROVE A
A RANGE OF ATTRIBUTES THAT EACH
LSE NEEDS TO MEET AND LEAVE TO
EACH LOC.
ARE HOW TO BEST DETERMINE TO
MEET THOSE ATTRIBUTES -- THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE -- JUST
THIS LAST THURSDAY -- THE CPC
ISSUED A RULING IDENTIFYING THAT
THERE'S AT LEAST TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF OF CAPACITY
SHORTFALL -- ANTICIPATED IN TWO
YEARS BY THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EDISON BUT WORKING
WITH COMMISSION STAFF ON THAT
OUR OWN ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT
THE SHORTFALL MAYBE AS MUCH AS
SEVEN OR EIGHT THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. TO PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT THAT'S ABOUT 15% OF THE
TOTAL DEMAND AT PEAK -- IT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE OUR WANTS TO
COOLEY FACILITIES ARE RETIRING
WHICH THEY SHOULD -- IT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE THE NET PEAK
ON THE SYSTEM IS MOVING FROM THE
MIDDLE OF SUMMER TO SEPTEMBER.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
SUNSHINE IN SEPTEMBER RIGHT THE
SUN GOES DOWN SOONER SO THE
SOLAR -- PROJECTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN INVESTING IN ARE NOT THAT
EFFECTIVE IN SEPTEMBER OF THE
WIND DOESN'T BLOW THAT MUCH
SEPTEMBER BASICALLY YOU GET
ABOUT 15% OF THE OUTPUT OF THE
SOLAR AND WIND PROJECT IN
SEPTEMBER SO.
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN
NEXT TWO YEARS IF WE DON'T WANT
TO HELP OUR LIABILITY SITUATION
LIKE WE DID DURING THE ENERGY
CRISIS I'M HAPPY TO SHARE.
WITH FOLKS HOW THAT CAME AMOUNT
OF THAT WE HAVE ENFORCEMENT OF
ALL L. THIS SEASON MEETING THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF THE RELIABILITY
AND CLEAN ENERGY REQUIREMENTS.
NOBODY'S GONNA TELL THE CCA WHAT
SPECIFIC PROJECT TO BUY OR BUILD
NO ONE'S GOING TO NULLIFY
SOMEONE'S CONTRACT WHAT THEY
WILL SAY IS YOU NEED X. Y. Z.
ATTRIBUTES IN YOUR PORTFOLIO.
PROOF PROOF TO US THAT YOU'VE
DONE THAT.
AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE UNDER UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IT THE PCD.
DOES NOT HAVE.
ADEQUATE AUTHORITY -- TO TO
ENFORCED THE RELIABILITY OF
CONCERNS OF OF THE C. C. A. R.
R. I. R. PEAS.
AT EDISON BELIEVES THAT THERE
ACTUALLY IS SUFFICIENT AUTHORITY
IN AND THE LAW FOR THE CPC -- TO
TO ENFORCE THESE -- ATTRIBUTE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CCA AND EASE
P. COMMUNITY -- SIGNIFICANTLY
CONTEST THAT ARE AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE SUPPORT SB ONE FIFTY
FIVE IT'S MAKING CLEAR UP THE
DOES IN FACT THE CPC'S ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BOB.
EFFORT RE RE WOULD DISLIKE HIM
TO YEAH OUR FIRST LOOK MUMMY
RESPOND THAT THE CCA'S LANGUAGE
TOTALLY UNDERMINES THE AUTHORITY.
OF THE P. YOU SEE TO DO THEIR
JOB IF YOU READ WHAT HAS BEEN OP
ARE AS IT RELATES TO JUST WHAT
MR CHRISTIE STATED.
THE R. P. -- OVERSIGHT IS A BI
ANNUAL REVIEW.
THEY'VE JUST COMPLETED THE FIRST
TWO YEARS AND THAT'S WHAT'S COME
BACK WITH THE REPORT THE STATE
THAT WERE IN NEED OF MORE
RELIABILITY.
AND I SIT HERE AS PRIDE THE ONLY
pWORK FOR UTILITY COMPANY.
TURN ENERGY CRISIS.
AND REAP LIABILITY OUTSIDE OF
SAFETY IS THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN.
AND YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE.
ENTITIES WHO WANT.
TO BEHAVE LIKE A UTILITY BUT
DON'T WANT TO BE REGULATED AND
MONITORED LIKE A UTILITY ARE THE
CURRENT.
LOWERED ITS SOUL.
A FLUCTUATING NOW BECAUSE OF
RENEWABLES LIKE LIKED MISTER
CHRISTIAN STATED EVERY NOBLE
COMMODITY IS NOT DISPATCH PULL.
IT INTERMENT ADD BASS SO YOU
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE PACKET OUT
WHAT OTHER RESOURCES BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S
AVAILABLE AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
AND NOT TO REPORT AND NOT TO
HAVE THIS OVERSIGHT LEAVES THIS
WHOLE STATE VULNERABLE AND WILL
BE SETTING THE CALIFORNIA UP
AGAIN.
AND WE COME BACK YEAR AFTER YEAR
BECAUSE WE MAKE A MAJOR MISTAKE
HERE WE LET LEGISLATORS WITH NO
EXPERIENCE AND POLICY -- AND
POWER IN GENERATION.
MAYBE WITH THIS EXCEPTION.
VERY FEW MAKE ENERGY POLICY HERE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WHY AS STATED WE DON'T
LAST THING WE WANTED TO LET OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
FOR I MEAN.
THAT WE DON'T.
SO WE NEED TO BE UC'S OVERSEE S.
SITE WE NEED TO SEE YOU SEE WE
NEED THOSE FOLKS WHO.
ARE PAID TO DO THIS.
AND EXPERIENCE TO DO IT MR WHAT
SHOULD.
I WOULD JUST ADD MISTER.
CHAIRMAN I THINK THE THE THE
BEST ARGUMENT FOR THE NEED OF
THIS BILL WAS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION.
IN THAT THE FIRST DIRE P. REPORT
CAME BACK AND FOUND DEFICIENCIES.
WE NEED TO PROTECT AGAINST A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE.
A. C. C. A. R. D. S. P. WHO'S
COMPLETELY ABDICATED THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE EXTREME.
IF THE PC DOESN'T HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO GO IN AND FORCED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM IS SAFE AND RELIABLE WE
COULD REALLY BE IN THE SOUP.
AND SO WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THEY
HAVE APPEALED THE FIRST DIRE P.
WE'RE ALREADY INTO THE SECOND
OUR P. CYCLE AND THEY'RE STILL
TRYING TO APPEAL AND FIGHT OVER
THE FIRST.
ONE WHAT IF THIS CONTINUES AD
NAUSEAM AND YOU HAVE A P. YOU
SEE THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT THE ENTIRE
GRID THAT'S SIMPLY WHY THIS BILL
IS NEEDED.
MISTER TECH CAN I JUST MAKE ONE
LAST POINT. ONE RESPONSE THANK
YOU SIR -- FIRST OF ALL THERE
WAS EIGHT THE WITH SOME CCA'S
WHAT MR WATCHES TELLING YOU HALF
THE STORY ON IS THAT WITH SOME
CCA'S THEIR I. R. PEAS WERE
FOUND TO BE NOT COMPLETED.
BASED ON THE TECHNICAL ISSUE OF
HOW CRITERIA POLLUTANTS WAS
REPORTED THEY HAVE BEEN REFILED
THERE'S NO ISSUE WITH THEM SO
HE'S MADE AMOUNT MAKE AN AMOUNT
NOT A WHOLE HELL OF MOLE HILL
AND LAST POINT.
IS ALL THE ISSUES THAT SENATOR
BRADFORD RAISED ABOUT CONCERN
FOR THE STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
ETCETERA ETCETERA ETCETERA.
I MEAN IF IF THAT'S THE CONCERN.
YOU KNOW THE IRP PROCESS IS THE
LEAST OF THE PROBLEMS THE BIG
PROBLEM IS THAT ONE OF THE THREE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES WENT IS
IN BANKRUPTCY.
THAT'S THE BIG PROBLEM AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE SORT OF HAVE
THIS IN PERSPECTIVE ALL THIS
NIGHTMARE SCENARIO THAT STATED
REALLY IS NOT A CONCERN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE SO.
AS BRADFORD THE THE COMMITTEE --
HAS REVIEWED YOUR BILL WERE DONE
IN ALICE'S SIDE WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IT TO PASS -- WE
ARE.
THIS IS NOT A CONDEMNATION ON
CCA'S OF THIS IS A RECOGNITION
THAT THERE IS A MARKET THAT WE
HAVE TO BE VERY KEENLY AWARE OF
THAT IS FRAGILE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE --
ANTICIPATING AND CERTAINLY THE
CPUC PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
IN ALL OF THIS THAT RESOURCE
ADEQUACY IS AN AREA THAT WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO TO BE VIGILANT
OVER -- THERE WILL BE RETIRING
OF OF PLANTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT.
CAN CONTINUE TO PUT US IN A
VULNERABLE POSITION -- TO THE
POINT WHERE THE CPUC HAS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
GOING TO LET THEM GO OFFLINE SO.
THERE IS A A LOT OF SHIFTING
GOING ON OUT THERE AND THOSE WHO
ARE -- ACTIVELY I THINK IS YOUR
BILL IS TRYING TO SAY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN
THIS MARKET PLACE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A RECOGNITION.
THAT PERFORMANCE STATES TO BE
OUT OF A LEVEL THAT'S LOOKING TO
THE LARGE SHORT.
MEDIUM AND LONG TERM -- SO WE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR POSITION TODAY
WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS --
THERE NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
CENTER BRADFORD IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE I I THINK YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I SURMISED IT'S
ADEQUATE CLOSE I WOULD TO STATE
I AM ALSO JUST WOULD RESPOND TO
THE QUESTION OF LONG TERM
CONTRACTS.
AGAIN WHAT THE IN OUR RESPONSES
INTO ENERGY CRISIS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE WAS A
FAILURE TO ENTER INTO LONG TERM
CONTRACTS TO LOCK IN PROCUREMENT
AT A STABLE PRICE.
THIS YEAH I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT NO ONE SEEMS TO MENTION
THAT BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I THINK THAT
THERE WAS -- AT LEAST AT THE
FIRST PART OF THIS THERE IS A
RECOGNITION THAT -- I GUESS WHEN
THE BILL WAS IN THE SENATE THERE
WERE SOME AREA OF AND QUESTION
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT SO I ASSUME
THAT.
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE AND
YOU.
HAVE A DIALOGUE -- THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THIS IS A I'M SORRY.
THE MOTION A SECOND THIS IS A DO
PASS -- TO NATURAL RESOURCES
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
SB ONE FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN HI PATTERSON.
PATTERSON ON A BURKE.
BURKE I CUT A DEAL.
I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES MAYES I MERIT CG NOT
VOTING NOT VOTING.
WORK I WORK HI REYES.
REYES ICE SANTIAGO.
TEEN [inaudible]
TING HI.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS. ELEVEN
IN FAVOR WILL HOLD OVER OPEN I
KNOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL I
WILL BE BRIEF MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON IRAQ SEVEN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. FOR
THE TASTE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WILL WILL TURN -- TO SO
THAT -- WILL APPRECIATE THE THE
SENATORS [inaudible] THREE FIVE
PRESENTATIONS.
WELL WELCOME THOSE WHO ARE HERE
TO TESTIFY OR TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PENNY PUT A
WALL ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHEN MEMBERS REBEKAH LEE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON POLICE REPORT THAT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN EDISON WAS ABLE
TO SECURE 46% OF OUR CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES FROM DIVERSE
ENTERPRISE AND A CONCERT YOU
ABOUT.
OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS REVENUE
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES SO IT'S AS
THE AS THE ENERGY MARKET
INVOLVES IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL COMMUNITIES CAN
YOU.
CAN CONTINUE TO BENEFIT FROM
THESE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
THANK.
THE CLEAN AND HONEST GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC ALSO IN SUPPORT.
OKAY -- YES.
LET'S SEPARATE ON BEHALF OF
KALENJIN CHAMBER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE MANY HUNTER
ON BEHALF OF CALCITE A OUIJA LSA
IN SIERRA THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
YOU CHAIRMAN HOLDEN AND SENATOR
BRED FOR FOR WORKING SO HARD ON
THE MINUTES.
WE LOOK FOR DELIVERING THE
LANGUAGE AND ACTUALLY REMOVING
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
LARA PART ON BEHALF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS WE
WILL ALSO BE RE REVIEW IN THE
AMENDMENTS AND HOPING TO REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WITHOUT -- ANY OTHER --
TESTIMONY AND OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR ANY
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
IS THERE A MOTION.
HAVE A MOTOR IN THE EVIDENCE.
YEAH.
OKAY -- CENTER BRADFORD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO I RESPECTFULLY I
STRUGGLE THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING -- LOOKING
JUST AT THE AS JUST FOR THE
RECORD -- GENERAL ORDER ONE
FIFTY SIX AND A FORMER MEMBER
GLENN MOORE'S EFFORTS BEHIND
THIS -- YOU HAVE BEEN STEADFAST
IN YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TRY TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT THE OF THE
MARKET PLACE OF OPPORTUNITY
CONTINUES TO EXPAND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE AND
IT'S GOOD BILL WE'RE PROUD TO BE
ABLE.
TO RECOMMEND IT TO PASS
[inaudible]
AS AMENDED -- TO APPROPRIATIONS
YES.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE TO MEMINTA
FELT THE SENATE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY BROKE UP WITH.
SB TWO FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THIS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO I CHEN.
CHEN I CUNNINGHAM.
IN HIM I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES I MURATSUCHI.
WEARS TO CHEAT I WORK OUR WORK I
REYES.
REYES I SANTIAGO.
TEEN.
TEEN HI.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BILLS OUT.
OKAY THE TWELVE VOTES SO -- WE
WILL NOW GO BACK -- TO THE TOP
OF THE ORDER ON THE FILE AND
WILL LOOK TO ADD ON TO THE
BILL'S AT THIS POINT WILL START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
MAKE OUR WAY THE TOP OF THE
FRONT.
A CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BURKE.
OKAY.
IF.
SB SEVENTEEN OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THAT THE MANDATE TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
THIRTEEN BUT THIS WOULD TO ON
THE LAST [inaudible]
ONE OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THAT'S AN OPTION THE THIRTEEN
OKAY THERE THIRTEEN VOTES IN
FAVOR OF ADOPTION OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CONSEIL OTHER.
CAN'T CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
NEXT ITEM IS SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY FIVE BRADFORD.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY FIVE ON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE HAS SWELLED.
FIVE MEASURES TWELVE VOTES.
HI THAT'S SPU ONE FIFTY FIVE
BRADFORD.
ARE YOU WANT.
TO WELL WELL DESPICABLE.
OKAY THE NEXT ITEM IS -- SB TWO
FORTY SEVEN DODD.
SB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS THE MENDOCINE NATURAL
RESOURCES BURKE.
BURKE AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I..
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES MAYES I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI.
YEAH FOURTEEN FOURTEEN VOTES IN
FAVOUR.
I WILL MOVE TO ITEM.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO FIFTY FIVE
BRADFORD.
SB TWO FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SON.
OUR WATER GARCIA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO ON THIRTY VOTES IN
FAVOR [inaudible]
SB. FIVE FIFTEEN CABALLERO.
SB FIVE FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES BURKE.
BURKE I IT WATER GARCIA
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO EIGHTEEN TING I
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI.
RAY S. RAY S. I OKAY -- LET'S
JUST MAKE SURE WE'VE GOT
EVERYTHING. THIRTEEN ON THE OKAY
[inaudible]
SO.
SB.
SEVENTY WITHIN A FOR US SANTIAGO.
EDUARDO GARCIA SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I SO WE HAVE FORTY
FORTY VOTES IN FAVOR ON THE
CONCERN -- DOCTOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- SB ONE FIFTY FIVE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS THAT DO
PASSED TO NATURAL RESOURCES --
EDUARDO GARCIA SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I THIRTEEN GEN JOHN SP
ONE FIFTY FIVE FROM ALL RIGHT.
A CUNNINGHAM CHAIN MUNICIPAL
FROM.
HI TO NOT VOTING.
SOMEONE [inaudible]
FIFTY FIVE AND THAT'S THANKS
[inaudible]
YEAH WOW [inaudible] TWO WOMEN.
ALMOST TWELVE VOTES ON THAT --
ONE EVERYBODY BUT WATER WORKS
THE NIGHT THERE ON THIS.
EVERYBODY ELSE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
YES THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS YEAH
WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING.
FIND OUT MISTER GARCIA.
SO WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN ON
FOR ALL OF OUR BILLS AND TO FOR
ANOTHER. FIVE MINUTES HELLO
MISTER GARCIA. TO JOIN US --
YEAH TO GET ENOUGH OF THAT RIGHT.
LADIES [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
QUESTION [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
REALLY
.
OKAY WE'RE GOING -- TO WE'VE.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLE --
WE HAVE -- VOTES THAT HAVE
BECAUSE THESE BILLS TO BE --
MOVED FORWARD AND SO THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
THESE REPORTS